[Music]
it is time now for our morning cup of
joe
with metro sheriff joe lombardo good
morning sheriff happy new year
happy new year good morning wanted to
ask you as we get into this new year we
are done with 2020. what are three goals
for the department for this year
i anticipate the goals are going to be
continuance of addressing violent crime
and quality of life and that's been one
of my goals since i got elected
and i'm actually very proud of our
success associated with both of those
particular issues outside of that
it would be homelessness and mental
health how we
address that as a law enforcement agency
and the resources associated with
addressing that
sheriff there was a mom here in las
vegas recently accused of accidentally
shooting her three-year-old
with gun safety and the increase in gun
purchases recently what do people need
to know about securing their firearms
a lot of people are amateurish i guess
that's a word
associated with firearms and what i mean
by that they don't understand the
how volatile they can be you know it's a
it's a it's a
device intended for death you know
hiding it under the cushions on the
couch or up on the shelf in a closet is
not sufficient enough to
address that particular issue and the
experience so
you know you get a modicum of experience
when you go get your your
ccw license i think that's what occurred
with this
individual with the three-year-old they
had the minimum amount of experience
in order to get the firearm it's
important that you practice with it
you learn it and practice safety
measures
with a firearm because unfortunately the
situation that a three-year-old who's
defenseless
was put in we have to deal with last
year sheriff this morning there's been a
number of mailbox break-ins
what should you do if this happens
obviously you don't know a lot of times
what was taken because you didn't check
your mail
right um so you could look at it two
different ways one
is if you're aware of the mailbox being
damaged
you know vandalism or people trying to
break in
and you're not aware of any mail being
taken we will respond to those calls you
we we want you to call us don't minimize
it we want you to call us so we can
one help you get it repaired via the
postal service
or privately and take a crime report
and that we will in turn forward to the
postal service
so but if you are aware that mail has
been stolen out of your mailbox
it's important that we get called on
those also and we will facilitate the
meeting with the postal inspector who
will respond
and take a report because that becomes a
federal crime i guess the bottom line is
get us involved
if um you suspect any kind of vandalism
or
theft from the mailboxes yeah that is a
good service too so you know what you're
supposed to get on the day of
all right sheriff joe lombardo thank you
for joining us sir it's great to see you
absolutely alex you take care
you too if you have a question for
sheriff joe lombardo send it to us on
our website
newsnow.com find out if your question
was answered every wednesday